bonsoir deux otages français libérés
jean louis normandin antenne 2 et roger
au sont libres depuis 17h30 dans
quelques instants
premiers témoignages réactions en direct
avant cela revenons tout de suite sur
les circonstances de la libération des
otages tout avait commencé hier soir par
un communiqué de logivière l'épilogué
est intervenu cet après midi dans un
complexe balnéaire à l'entrée de
beyrouth-ouest à beyrouth
confirmation avec jacques charlot le
calvaire et jean louis normandin
ils ont tous les deux été libérés à
beyrouth le journaliste de rtl
après des mois de captivité normandin
l'éclairagiste d'antenne 2 après 20 mois
ils ont été transportés par leurs
ravisseurs dans le coffre d'une voiture
de leur lieu de détention jusqu'à
l'hôtel summerland dans le secteur
musulman de la capitale libanaise
ils ont du chemin de la liberté à pied
les services de sécurité de l'ambassade
de france
prévenus par un communiqué diffusé une
heure avant dans l'organisation de la
justice révolutionnaire était là pour
les accueillir
après de longues tractations avec les
services de sécurité l'armée syrienne
qui contrôle des routes ouest et deux
libérés sont montés dans les 6 3/4 plein
des ambassades de france pour gagner le
secteur chrétien père ou autre et
normandin et des balles et amaigri et
tvq sommairement de t-shirts et 2 et
andy camp avec succès là ils ont fait
preuve d'une étonnante résistance pour
deux hommes qui ont connu l'enfer
pendant de longs mois
voilà pour les faits je pense que nous
sommes en mesure maintenant d'écouter la
première interview la première réaction
de jean louis normandin c'était il ya
quelques minutes sur l'antenne de nos
confrères d'europe 1 prêtait bien
l'oreille car la conversation et est
difficilement audible jean louis
normandin
mais 3g japon la chine et la suisse et a
traversé les graviers entre 1 2 et 3 et
6 3 fermer la radio
voilà c'était vous l'avez compris il ya
quelques minutes sur l'antenne de nos
confrères tout de suite d'autres
réactions les parents de jean louis
normandin sont avec nous en direct de
bordeaux vous avez eu confirmation de la
nouvelle à 17h30 est-ce que déjà avant
on vous avait confirmé la bonne nouvelle
oui nous pressentions bien sûr une
libération et nous avons été avertis que
par une agence de fp au départ c'est
canal+ aux infos de 22 heures qui nous a
appris une libération d'otages mais nous
n'avions qu'une aucune précision quant à
savoir qui seraient libérés
étant donné que dans le communiqué de
logivière il avait la photo de jean
louis nous espérons nous espérions bien
que ce serait lui qui seraient libérés
mais nous n'avons pas la certitude il a
fallu attendre la confirmation par les
autorités françaises du fait que c'était
bien jean louis rault shylock été
libérée pendant la période de détention
de votre fils est ce que vous êtes resté
en contact permanent avec le quai
d'orsay
oui absolument nous sommes en contact
permanent avec les lancers et j'ai la
certitude que
le quai d'orsay et le gouvernement ont
fait tout ce qu'il fallait faire pour
arriver à cette libération
spontanément aussi à normandin quelle a
été votre première réaction quand vous
avez appris la libération de votre fils
c'est une immense soupir de soulagement
de le savoir libre et de dire enfin ce
calvaire est terminé
j'aperçus antoine 8 ans et demi qui est
le fils de jean louis
il a toujours gardé confiance en toi
comment ça s'est passé pour toi ça pas
dû être évident s'avérer un jour sur
toujours cru en toi
oui j'y ai toujours cru et y a qu il que
et que tout à l'heure que je n'étais que
je que j'en ai les faire ses études
qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire avec
ton père maintenant
ouais ça serait un beau cadeau de noël
merci qu'ils étaient heureux ce soir
métier surtout ému un antoine et et ça
se comprend
merci merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur une très belle soirée pour
vous vous retrouvez votre fils demain
vous savez déjà on vous a déjà dit à
quelle heure il rentrait non non nous
étonne informations de matignon qui doit
nous fixe chez l'heureux d'arriver rue
semblables de jean louis à paris
et évidemment nous serons là-bas pour
l'accueillir ça c'est absolument sûr
j'en suis j'en suis persuadé avec ses
compagnons de reportages qui sont avec
nous à les plateaux je suis certain que
l'équipe sera pour une fois au grand
complet que les trois mousquetaires
seront bientôt tous les 4 réunit c'est
le cas vous dire que les mousquetaires
en sourire à vous les avez vu on leur
posera des questions tout à leur merci à
vous françois mitterrand vient d'envoyer
un télégramme aux otages je partage
votre joie dit le président de la
république et mes pensées vont à nos
compatriotes qui ne sont pas encore
libérés d'autres réactions si tout va
bien madame o qui est avec nous en
direct des studios défaire 3 lille
bonsoir madame monsieur lussier pour
vous comme pour les parents de jean
louis normand basse et c'est la fin d'un
cauchemar véritablement oui s'il a fait
des cauchemars et j'en suis très
heureuse je t'ai très heureuse que rouge
et libéré alors l'enlèvement de votre
fils n'avait jamais été vraiment
revendiquer
nous on est jamais été revendiqués et
les dernières heures madame on était
d'autant plus dur pour vous que vous ne
saviez pas si c
si roger allait être véritablement
libéré oui c'est vrai c'était très dur
enfin chez qu'il sera là demain vous
saviez que le métier qu'il faisait là
bas était un métier difficile vous en
aviez parlé avec lui
oui mais enfin roger a toujours voulu je
pense faire ce match il ya oui et il
faisait incontestablement il fait le
plus beau métier il a il a voulu aller
jusqu'au bout oui vous êtes êtes heureux
ce soir vous ne montrez pas madame créer
et surtout ému vous serez à paris demain
pour la calle serait un pari merci aurel
cornéa georges en scène et philippe
rochot les compagnons de reportage de
jean louis normandin est aussi pris en
otage le lit mars 86 sont venus nous
rejoindre vous les avez vus sur le
plateau je suppose que vous aussi vous
êtes pour une joie très intense ce soir
je suis c'est un immense soulagement et
une grande joie un vrai bonheur parce
que ces libérations que tous les trois
on attendait depuis notre libération et
que comme dit si justement philippe une
20 juin 90 relâché et aujourd'hui on est
libre alors en écoutant le récit de la
libération de jean louis normandin je
pense qu'il ya bon nombre d'image qui
ont dû revenir dans la tête des images
qui sont pas toujours très très belle
oui ce qui est évident c'est toujours le
même comportement de l'otage finalement
quand ils retrouvent la liberté bon on
parle de sa détention jean louis n'a pas
l'air très très marquée finalement il
dit j'ai été bien traité c'était aussi
notre sentiment avant quand on a été
libéré et puis après on fait le tri on
voit ce qui est bien ce qui est mal et
quand on sort c'est toujours très très
difficile et je croyais en lui il y aura
beaucoup de semaines a examiné son cas
exact et puis se remettre d'aplomb on a
très peu entendu un jean louis normandin
tout à l'heure j'espère que nous
pourrons peut-être la voir qui c'est
avant la fin d'émission
les gens tendaient georges en scène qui
parlait ce midi dans le journal de 13h
avec william leymergie disent qu'il ya
une petite complicité entre guillemets
avec certains preneurs d'otages y en a
certains qui parlent plus que d'autres
et c'est un peu comme ça vous que vous
aviez appris comment vous alliez être
pas comprendre leur d'otages et et nous
gardiens parce que mais c'est vrai que
différents oui je crois que c'est vrai
que quelques jours avant d'allumer ma
libération à nous sommes nous gravi
soeur était un peu plus sympa que les
autres et vous avez laissé entendre
qu'une libération possible sur les dents
on sentait ça dans l'air on y croyait
fermement mais moi on part je suis
partagé cette même information avec jean
louis normand le vendredi soir quatre
sont venus me chercher je suis prêt si
c'était pour me libérer pour nous
libérer
c'est la croatie tous les quatre ans et
vous n'avez retrouver on avait retrouvé
crier qu'ils avaient retrouvé dans la
dans la pièce mitoyenne philippe kimathi
georges ne libérer alors je marche un
immense cri de joie mais je croyais
qu'il était mais à l'époque on pensait
qu'on sera libéré tous les cas c'est
d'abord aux six cantons ont discuté
entre nous elle va il disait toujours
mais non on peut pas me libérer
séparément on sera libéré tous les
quatre et donc on pensait que dans la
demi-heure qui suivrait il nous
rejoindrait et finalement il a fallu
attendre quatre mois pour voir aurel et
puis et puis en plus 15 mois pour vous
alors aurel cornéa lui c'était le
preneur de sons l'ingénieur du son de
l'équipe c'est lui qui a vu jean louis
normandin pour la dernière fois avec lui
ben six mois et demi où est le jour le
monde de para
on se dit tous les deux que on aura
attendre pour voir une dizaine de jours
je n'y pensais pas du tout que ça va
être une dizaine de mois dans quel état
d'esprit se trouve est il à ce confort
dont au rebond en très bonne santé
morale et physique est solide il n'avait
jamais je n'avais jamais craquer il ya
jamais eu dans des silos mais
apparemment l'aller les premiers propos
que nous venons d'entendre témoigne
effectivement d'une grande vitalité le
presqu'île et j'espère que changer vous
êtes heureux ce soir faut que c'est pas
la peine de le dire et de le redire et
la plus belle image que nous
présenterons celle de vous 4 réunit la
même équipe celle qui avait été enlevée
donc le 8 mars 86 à beyrouth libération
de jean louis normandin et de roger
auque
mais la france compte toujours trois
otages au liban philippe lefait vendredi
22 mars 1985 il ya plus de deux ans et
demi le début du calvaire à beyrouth
pour les diplomates carton et fontaine
est une nouvelle donne pour la politique
de la france au proche orient
la prise d'otages deux mois plus tard
jour pour jour en mai sur la route de
l'aéroport deux autres français sont
enlevés
de nouveau la djihad islamique photos à
l'appui revendiquent les enlèvements du
sociologue michel seurat et du
journaliste de l'événement du jeudi jean
paul kauffmann les ravisseurs met en
cause la diplomatie et la politique
antiterroriste de la france à paris la
solidarité s'organise l'affairé sur la
place publique et les émissaires se
succèdent à beyrouth en vain pour les
femmes des otages joëlle kauffmann par
exemple qui découvre ici les réalités du
liban où madame fontaine une longue
errance commence à la recherche de ce
qui pourrait ouvrir des portes notamment
les dignitaires chiites libanais
à beyrouth l'organisation jihad
islamique annonce avoir exécuté l'un des
quatre otages français michel seurat
c'était il ya 18 mois
depuis marie sera s'est enfermé dans la
discrétion d'une mort qui n'a jamais été
confirmée nous sommes le 27 novembre
trois de ces quatre hommes restent les
otages français au liban
je vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
joëlle kauffmann les pousses de jean
paul kauffmann réactions enregistrées
avant que l'on connaisse la lennon
l'identité des deux otages libérés à
beyrouth aujourd'hui joëlle kauffmann
après onze mois de creux comme ça avec
aucune libération c'est formidable ça
veut dire que la roue tourne peut-être
dans l'autre sens en même temps j'ai
comme une inquiétude parce que le groupe
hier libère ses otages et il semble que
le groupe j à 2 et des raisons de les
garder beaucoup plus profonde alors ce
que j'espère aujourd'hui vraiment très
franche très contente pour les familles
de ceux qui vont rentrer on a toujours
un petit coin j'espère que c'est
peut-être aussi le sien puisque les noms
sont adonnés on est un peu comme ça et
que j'espère qu'en tout cas cette
libération là c'est la mort d'un
processus de libération pour les pour
les 5 et pas du tout une libération
séparer négocier séparément
voilà chez nous vous en doutez à antenne
2 la libération de jean louis normandin
a été accueilli avec beaucoup de joie à
une immense émotion a dit certain à
17h30 ou un peu plus de 17 heures 30
il s'est incontestablement passé quelque
chose de très fort l'émotion se lisait
d'ailleurs sur tous les visages monsieur
le président oui c'est une émotion
c'est une grande joie pour tous ceux qui
à antenne 2 attendait le retour de jean
louis normandin
c'est une grande joie aussi pour tous
ceux qui pensent aux parents de jean
louis normandin que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure et qui ont été exemplaire de
courage dans cette épreuve
c'est aussi le souci partagé pour ceux
qui restent détenus et c'est enfin un
sentiment de
gratitude pour tout ce lait ou de
l'autorité de l'état le gouvernement le
premier ministre et tous ceux qui ont
contribué à cette libération
aujourd'hui comme le disait tout à
l'heure monsieur normandin la famille
d'antenne 2 est au complet
monsieur le président je vous remercie
je me permets de vous interrompre car je
pense que nous avons et si la technique
marche jean louis normandin en direct
jean louis normandin vous les entendez
très bien alors votre sentiment ce soir
de la joie de l'émotion racontez-nous ce
qui s'est passé jean louis jusqu'au
dernier moment ça a été dur vous avez
douté
vous êtes libre l'a1
il faut se passer un peu pour y croire
mais c'est vrai vous savez que vos
compagnons de reportages en scène en
scène et la corneilla et laroche au sont
là qu est ce que vous avez un message à
leur transmettre à l'instant même y sont
sur le plateau à mon cas mais côté puis
nous écoutent oui oui il vous écoute là
ils peuvent d'ailleurs peut-être venir
me rejoindre et dialoguer avec vous
venez or elle est encore là je sais pas
si philippe et là il il vous écoute il
vous écoute alesi venez genre demande de
venir nous rejoindre sur le plateau je
venais passer derrière moi il est venu
vers lui tous les attend alors demain
n'oublie pas tout est pour le mieux dans
le meilleur des mondes possibles
comme on le disait m un gosse jean-louis
si vous voyez le regard et leur sourire
là ce soir je peux vous dire que vous
pourriez croire véritablement à votre
libération tant et si bien qu'on puisse
y ait encore vous poser les questions
les bravo pour ton courage et bravo pour
votre courage qu est ce que vous allez
faire là qu'est ce que vous faites dans
l'immédiat
il m'a arraché des mains des syriens
parce que ce n'est pas tout d'être si
c'était très dur jusqu'à la fin est
retrouvé par des militaires syriens et
bon finalement ça fait bien passer la
questionnant l'ambassade et j'ai un beau
parce qu'on ne ferait arrivée en france
a retrouvé tout le monde ça va tellement
vite qu'on n'a pas le temps d'avoir peur
now l'instant de la libération
quelle image vous reste dans la tête
j'étais avec avec roger auque que j'ai
rencontré tout à l'heure dans le coffre
d'une voiture dit que je ne connaissais
pas du tout instant même coffre place de
la même voiture
je n'étais connaissance banque est
présente en délibéré entendre et demande
de l'arrivée des gens et des armes et
des appareils de photos c'était très dur
et puis avait une tension entre les
membres
et là vous avez couru jusqu'à 1 jusqu'à
l'hôtel là c'est un peu comme le lien il
ya quelques mois
alors oui on est libéré par l'activité
la voiture 50 mètres avant avant l'autre
avant l'autel et là on était donc m il
ya un militaire arrêté et nous promener
vos papiers
cela va être encore les arabes en armes
non là il y avait d'autres problèmes en
perspective
c'est le côté tout à fait anecdotique de
gens d'affaires
merci jean nuit bonne soirée on vous
laisse avec toute la joie titre émotions
intérieures que vous pouvez prouver ce
soir et éprouvent la grande majorité des
français toutes vos familles nous vous
retrouvons sur le plateau demain soir
sans doute un
c'est ici nous vous attendons antenne 2
vous attend si incertain merci bonsoir
bonsoir et merci carcérale est ce qu'on
sait dans quelles circonstances se sont
déroulées les négociations revient dès
des préoccupations plus terre à terre il
y avait la joie il y avait des motions
mais pas par définition ces négociations
sont secrètes ce que je remarque
simplement c'est que on n'a pas eu d'
envoyer particulier d'envoyés spéciaux
on parle de hauts fonctionnaires du
ministère de la défense en vain de la
défense et ont dit que finalement les
contacts sont noués et que les
l'organisation de la justice
révolutionnaire a bien voulu accepter de
relâcher les otages qu'elle détient à la
pause et quand même non pas des
conditions mais la craie en quelque
sorte dans le communiqué en tout cas les
apparences d'une de nouvelles conditions
dans le communiqué qu'elle a donnée pour
annoncer cette libération
d'abord un certain climat nouveau on
n'est pas très contents de la france non
pense qu'elle va arranger les choses
c'est peut-être ça qui a été négocié de
dire que finalement on va tenter de se
retrouver dans ces pays dans cette
région eh bien peut-être dans un plan
plus équilibrée à l'égard de l'irak où
l'égard d'israël ne sais pas mais c'est
peut-être ce qui les as this fait c'est
ce que j'appelle bon en fait le
contentieux fondamental qu'on peut avoir
entre ces extrémistes musulmans et les
nôtres alors apparemment pire c'est plus
le ministère de l'intérieur par le
ministère de la défense que le quai
d'orsay qui est intervenu dans cette
négociation pourquoi bah écoute et
apparemment si on se fie en tout cas ce
qu'on sait effectivement puisque les
cellules de crise se sont réunis autour
ne se passe quoi toute la journée au
ministère de l'intérieur et hier je
crois et la nuit dernière
en tout cas ce que je pense c'est
qu'effectivement il ya des moments où
certaines personnes certaines personnes
individuellement prennent les choses en
main ce qui est sûr c'est que peut-être
la diplomatie n'était pas absente c'est
quand même les ambassadeurs qu'ils ont
tapé pour récupérer les otages mais en
même temps je pense que certains
contacts avec certains personnages se
font par le biais un peu de l'ombre et
que dans l'ombre mais les diplomates
agissent pas tellement dans l'ombre
merci pierre c'est tout ce que l'on
pourrait dire tout au moins dans
l'immédiat pour ceux qui prendraient
l'antenne seulement maintenant je vous
rappelle que jean louis normandin
l'antenne ne et roger auque ont été
libérés cet après midi la france compte
encore malheureusement trois otages au
liban
jean paul kauffmann marcel carton et
marcel fontaine
une pensée également pour alain
guillot notre confrère qui a été capturé
en afghanistan le 12 septembre dernier
selon radio kaboul capter hier soir
notre confrère collecter des
informations concernant la défense du
pays
on ne sait pas quand et où il sera jugé
il est actuellement entre les mains de
l'armée régulière afghane en haïti
confusion et violence confusion et
violence à la veille des élections
présidentielles les nostalgiques de jean
claude duvalier multiplient les
accrochages et les incidents au coeur de
port-au-prince
à l'extérieur la terreur continue trois
personnes ont été tuées hier soir à 150
km de la capitale
bref c'est dans un climat de tension
extrême que lille va tenter dimanche de
faire l'apprentissage de sa démocratie
sur place une correspondance de martine
laroche joubert à une centaine de
kilomètres de la capitale port au prince
la région de l'artibonite scènes
paisibles paysage tranquille mais aussi
des rumeurs de pressions d'intimidation
à la veille des élections
c'est le fief des macoutes nous sommes
ici depuis une demi heure à peine
qui c'est qui a tiré la cote son parti
m'a consulté la machine la machine
soulagement pour les paysans et pour
nous mêmes
d'autres n'ont pas eu cette chance ce
matin là dans le village de borel trois
morts trois morts pour rien tuer au
hasard
je me cachais à l'intérieur de la maison
en neuf ans j'ai vu trois militaires va
la cour il avait déjà tué un homme
dehors quand même le jeu réussit très
pour voter moi je mourrai avec mon butin
dont le prix d'un vote ici c'est
quelquefois la mort souvent la violence
et l'intimidation pour aider les
haïtiens quelques hommes de bonne
volonté comme le père salvetti 12 ans en
haïti
c'est là qu'il ya eu l'incendié du
bureau électoral pour l'histoire
ces communales du bureau électoral
communal et c'est là où est mort c'est
là qu'est mort le jeune homme jean marie
jean baptiste gym au vert c'est la
volonté de tout secteur duvaliériste
macoutes d'empêcher les élections tout
simplement
les trois responsables de ce bureau
électoral se cachent leurs familles et
leurs enfants aussi les macoutes sont
sur leurs traces dans une mer aussi
tendu de prévoir si des élections se
déroulent régulièrement effectivement
sur place et l'incertitude les images
étaient signées jacques dau et tout de
suite les autres télégramme de
l'étranger commenté par pascal vanier
tué à coups de hache des missionnaires
chrétiens dumas tabac l'elorn 16 blanc
et 4 noir assassiné de sang froid ici
dans leur ferme victimes des opposants
au gouvernement de robert mugabe
le flux l'indépendance 50 missionnaires
ont été sacrifiés au nom des luttes
tribales du zimbabwe
après quinze jours de troubles états
d'urgence décrétés au bangladesh
rassemblements et manifestations sont
interdits à 48 heures d'une nouvelle
grève lancée par l'opposition
elle réclame le départ du président r
chad les événements avaient déjà fait 25
morts et 1500 blessés
la presse parle en outre de 2500
arrestation les 27 otages de la prison
doc des libérés ce matin les
négociations avec les détenus cubains
semble véritablement engagée en voici la
première image
atlanta une centaine de personnes
restent aux mains des mutins 300 d'entre
eux se sont rendus les spécialistes de
la lutte antiterroriste cern toujours la
prison le typhon nina aura tué au moins
360 personnes c'est le dernier chiffre
publié par les autorités de manille 17
personnes sont portées disparues et onze
provinces et vaste qui ont été déclarées
zones sinistrées par la présidente akino
on dénombre 63000 sans abri à amiens
dans la somme les obsèques de lucien
barbier le militant cgt décédé à la
suite d'une manifestation se dérouleront
demain samedi
aujourd'hui on s'interroge sur les
circonstances de sa mort barbier le père
tranquille comme l'appelaient ses
voisins était un enfant du pays
son militantisme s'exprimait au
quotidien reportage de christophe martet
le parc des expositions damien c'est ici
que le 6 novembre lucien barbier
manifestent contre le tracé du tgv nord
en compagnie d'une centaine de militants
cgt
l'un d'eux raconte pour la première fois
les circonstances du drame et commence à
se disperser et les la police urbaine a
chargé
et on les met des banderoles de la cgt
qui étaient ici et à comment là ils ont
déchiré les banderoles et il ya un
policier qui le mât d'une banderole et
qui a frappé absurde reprises sur le
son copain il y avait vraiment une force
de frappe est vraiment d'une sauvagerie
du focus
saubi lier mon rival au coeur de la
somme agricole la famille de lucien
dardier reste silencieuse dans cette
maison où il vécu toute sa vie
les habitants du village se souviennent
de cet homme sans histoire c'était une
grande étendue tous disputés à porte qui
est que tous les clients et à vélo il
est connu si c'était lui bon quel est
votre action aujourd'hui malheureuse qui
fini
la mission paraît vraiment haut niveau
pour moi
demain une marche solennelle aura lieu
dans les rues d'amiens
de nombreuses personnalités dont georges
marchais et henri krasucki vont se
rendre devant l'hôtel de ville où une
chapelle ardente sera dressée en hommage
à lucien barbier
les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité commentée par isabelle staes
ensuite nous parlerons sport avec un
spécialiste jean mamère générique
aurillac écroué
le militant d'aix angosto palestinien
vient d'être inculpé d'association de
malfaiteurs après son interpellation
lundi en bretagne la dst avait découvert
chez lui des fiches de renseignements
sur les spécialistes de la lutte
antiterroriste et la doit retourner en
prison la cour d'appel de paris
un fille en leur donnant de mise en
liberté du directeur de l'hebdomadaire
corps fourie bon goût à sa charge des
documents liés aux activités de l'ex
flnc
ils ont été découverts le mois dernier
dans les locaux du journal
chapelle darblay dépose son bilan
mesures techniques pour assurer la
continuité du groupe papetier objectif
clarifier la situation financière en
incitant les créanciers à se manifester
les repreneurs plus nos cascades espère
ainsi évaluer avec précision le facile
estimé à 100 millions de francs
le sport tout d'abord un résultat de ski
à sestrières en italie c'est l'italien
alberto tomba qui a remporté le premier
slalom de la coupe du monde italien
devance dans l'ordre le suédois jonas
nilsson et l'autrichien madère le
français didier bouvet d'abord classé
19e a été malheureusement disqualifié en
rugby jean mamère étonnante disparition
d'un rugbyman roumains alors qu'il était
resté en france il ya une dizaine de
jours on comprend mal oui victor abraham
avait choisi de s'installer à agen au
sort de la rencontre france roumanie le
11 novembre dernier
on comprend mal sa disparition au moment
où la france vient de recevoir l'asile
politique et donc la protection du
gouvernement français il a quitté agen
en important toutes ces affaires
victor abraham a été aperçue pour la
dernière fois le mercredi soir vers 17
heures dans la nuit précédente vers une
heure du matin un témoin l'avait vu
quitter son hôtel
encadrés par deux hommes ces deux hommes
sont peut-être ceux qui se faisant
passer pour des roumains installés en
france mais porteurs de carte
diplomatique avait cherché à le joindre
dans la journée de mardi
une disparition donc surprenante car
victor avram venait de signer un contrat
d'employé au stade une licence au club
local reçu l'asile politique et des
papiers en règle de la sécurité sociale
après 48 heures de silence toutes les
hypothèses ce soir sont donc possibles
merci jean météo petites améliorations
en vue c'est pas mal pour le week-end
mais les températures resteront fraîches
ah oui effectivement nous allons parler
du retour d'un ami il nous manquait il
n'était pas très loin nous tout proche
mais enfin bon le ciel n'était plus tout
à fait le même c'est pourquoi bien
demain ça ira beaucoup mieux pour nous
cet ami vous l'avez compris c'est celle
entre anticyclone lui aussi est de
retour il est re de retour par
l'atlantique
c'est pourquoi sur des régions comme la
l'atlantique ici c'est par là que
revient d'anticyclone et donc sur des
régions largement marquée sur l'ouest de
la france et bien nous aurons de très
belles éclaircies avec un soleil qui
sera dominant nous garderons quelques
percées disons nuageuses sur l'est du
pays
beaucoup de soleil sur le pourtour
méditerranéen avec des vents de nord
quant aux températures effectivement
comme le disait henri tout à l'heure ces
températures restent fraîches pour la
saison
deux petits de grecs dans la région de
strasbourg c'est là qu'elles seront le
plus fraîches
j'en profite pour vous dire qu'il fera 6
degrés ici ici à roubaix
c'est là qu'est née roger où il est né à
roubaix et puis il faudra 7 degrés ici
du côté de de bordeaux à
fargues-saint-hilaire saint-hilaire
pardon c'est là qu'est né jean louis
normandin demain et bien le soleil se
lèvera à 8h19 il se couchera à 16h57
et ce sera saint jacques de la marche en
avant à londres chez christie's un
manuscrit inédit de franz liszt a été
vendu cet après midi cent ans après la
mort du compositeur franz liszt avait 19
ans quand il l'a composé à cette époque
là il côtoyait berlioz schumann et et
richard wagner pour la première fois
grâce à antenne 2 et aussi anne
queffélec au piano vous allez entendre
cette mélodie à la fois inédite et
insoupçonnée reportage christian giroux
et georges bigot dans l'église saint
vincent de paul à paris
liszt jouer de l'orgue il a vécu dans ce
quartier comme la concertiste anne
queffélec qui interprètent cette musique
composé ici est perdue depuis plus d'un
siècle et demi
j'ai de l'oeuvre d'un compositeur toujas
de 19 ans puisqu'il a écrit cette pièce
en 1830 et qu'on y sent tout à fait la
fureur de vivre si l'on peut dire comme
un james d un petit peu l'amour de la
ville
il remet très souvent sur la partition
d'ailleurs les termes de fureur fout
rien furore d'espira tôt il y à un autre
endroit où il écrit avec rage et donc on
sent qu'il y a vraiment un désir de
bouger beaucoup dit
à
d'où le génie romantique de liszt est en
germe dans les 36 pages de ce manuscrit
de jeunesse et c'est peut-être pour cela
que mise en vente aujourd'hui à londres
au prix de 200 mille francs
elle a finalement été adjugé 650 du trou
le vendeur et l'acheteur sont restés
anonymes aux ont souhaité que ces
collectionneurs soit au moins musiciens
et nous voilà je vous rappelle la
principale information du journal
d'antenne de 20 heures jean louis
normandin antenne 2 et roger auque les
deux otages français au liban sont
libres depuis cet après midi cette
libération fait suite au communiqué de
logivière publié hier soir jean louis
normandin été retenu en otage depuis six
ans 29 jours
roger auque depuis 319 jours ce soir
trois français jean paul kauffmann
marcel fontaine et marcel carton sont
toujours détenus au liban
pierre une dernière précision bon on
sait grosso modo comment se sont
déroulées les négociations vous en
parliez tout à l'heure
nos confrères sont de retour quand
demain vraisemblablement est-ce qu'on a
les détails techniques sur leur séjour
ils ont été libérés à beyrouth ways né
puisse au passé et qu'ils voient sur
l'ambassade à beyrouth est actuellement
ils sont donc dans le secteur chrétienne
de beyrouth et dans la résidence de
l'ambassadeur et pour le bon vous savez
il ya 2 tentation il ya la mer qui est
devant eux et c'est la liberté et c'est
ça c'est par là qui veulent partir c'est
la porte ouverte et puis en plus de
l'autre côté il ya d'abbas apporte un
peu obligé je crois que ces six discute
c'est de savoir si vous passez
directoire par la mer c'est à dire aux
jaunards dacca et paris ou si vous
passez par d'abbas dans les deux cas
durera deux heures différence à leur
arrivée c'est généralement on fait
toujours le détour par damas qu'en
général un coup de chapeau à nos
confrères de la croix l'événement qui
dès cet après midi vous le voyez on fait
la une sur la libération des deux otages
français
liberté pour oak et normandes à ces
sorties dès cet après midi
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 pendant
le week end vous avez rendez vous avec
daniel bilalian philippe gassot et
bernard rapp aussi pour l'assiette
anglaise demain à 13h15 excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 et merci à vous
bonsoir
e